- C'est devant une piscine du
quartier Saint-Roch à Québec que
la brigade Splash a été lancée
pour sa 15e édition.
La tournée estivale permettra
comme à l'habitude de
sensibiliser les baigneurs,
de former les sauveteurs et
les gestionnaires
d'installations aquatiques.
Mais cette année, la vigilance
devra être relevée. Certaines
régions du Québec peinent à
recruter des sauveteurs et des
milliers de cours de natation
n'ont pas eu lieu en raison
de la pandémie.
RAYNALD HAWKINS, d.g. Société de
sauvetage, division du Québec.
- Les enfants n'ont pas suivi
de cours de natation depuis
les 15-16 derniers mois,
on prétend qu'ils deviennent
plus à risque justement d'être
victimes de noyade, de là toute
l'importance de pouvoir dire
autant à un moniteur de camp
d'été, de camp de jour,
vos fréquentez des lieux de
baignade, vous avez un rôle et
un mandat de responsabilité
de surveiller.
Selon les données non-
officielles de la Société
de sauvetage, 28 décès liés à
l'eau sont déjà survenu cette
année au Québec, comparativement
à 32 décès à pareil date
l'an dernier.
- Vous voyez qu'on est sans
jouer dans les mots, dans
les mêmes eaux en terme de
nombre, et c'est pour ça qu'on
fait cet appel à la prudence.
Et la tragique noyade d'un
enfant de 10 ans à la base de
plein air de St-Foy la semaine
dernière, représente un triste
rappel des risques de
la baignade.
Mais pour l'instant,
8le gouvernement attent le
rapport du coroner sur l'affaire
pour déterminer si le port
du gilet de sauvetage lors des
sorties scolaires à la piscine
pourrait devenir obligatoire.
ANDRÉE LAFOREST, ministre
Affaires municipales, Habitation
- On va regarder ce qui se passe
au niveau de l'enquête, mais
dites vous que dans tous
les ministères impliqués, on a
pris ça très au sérieux. On
étudie la situation on va
attendre quand même le rapport
d'enquête.
- En attendant, Sylvie Bernier,
une ancienne plongeuse olympique
qui a elle-même perdu son neveu
dans une noyade, lance un appel
pour rattraper le temps perdu
quant aux cours de natation.
SYLVIE BERNIER, marraine
d'honneur, Nager pour survivre
- On se rend compte qu'il y a à
peine 50 % des enfants qui
savent nager. On sait tous
se baigner, les deux pieds
vraiment qui touche le fond de
la piscine, mais la minute que
les enfants perdent pied
ou tombent abruptement d'un
quai, ils ne savent pas nager.
- L'an dernier, 95 décès liés à
l'eau sont survenus au Québec.
Ici Colin Côté-Paulette,
Radio-Canda, Qu